während der einfache arbeiter sind
italienische italienische schule ist die
größte scheiß cent genau hier und heute
geht es den francesco man
austauschpartner austria es besuchen in
trier sind dazu steht es mit dem zug in
fahren wir sehen uns
sie sonnen
unser zug ausgefüllt
2000 jahre aber das schöne kleid mit der
vhs
bevor die de der language world cities
der wahnsinn häufigste form
meine musik ist ihr geschäft
denn carl spitteler cop track ist
angekommen
erstens weil irgendwie dieses
wiedersehen so ich war schon mal hier
jetzt wegen meinem ausgesparten speaker
schön und den christen sehen wir später
auch noch jetzt gucken so ein bisschen
die stadt an education
dr
so leute werden es einen kleinen snack
und ich habe mir eine sonnenbrille
gekauft und ich finde es ganz cool weil
sie ständig niesten bringen und jetzt
geht es wahrscheinlich noch mal vor an
den steg so ähnlich zumindest und dann
schauen wir was weitergeht aber dann
geht es auf jeden fall zum mittagessen
super test und wir sind
gefühlt den ganzen tag hier messen
du willst du bist
wir sind jetzt angekommen bei meiner
haustür corsa interesse aus deutschland
faust ist scheiße um gehören deutsche
literatur schreiben gerade in der glasur
also morgen nicht nur über faust luca
die tuberkulose entweder ex kgb
einzelwerke jakl wir essen jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal zum mittag dreck und
ich werde einfach mal die ganzen jungs
auch ins tram verlinkt weil die böden
alle gerne fotos von daher verlinkt ich
die mal klima aus und dann sehen wir uns
beim essen wieder was es geht
das stimmt überhaupt nicht es überhaupt
nicht als mega waren hier sonne scheint
ein 25 grad warm ist einfach kaputt weil
dieses überhaupt nicht gewohnt sind hier
mit einem 2 gibt's noch ein abendessen
bisher war schon bekannt
der in aspik wir sind gerade noch fertig
messen und jetzt lernen wir gerade ein
bisschen hier für deutsch geschichte für
geschichte und ich war hier den
francesco totti zusammenfassung und mode
gastfreundschaft
das ist wirklich eklig also die lernen
nur nur so sachen wie faust und woyzeck
und so was also nur so eklige literatur
und überhaupt keinen kein wirklichkeit
bezug zum und also muss schon sagen wir
uns das schulsystem wirklich ein
bisschen besser finde ich eigentlich
auch wenn sich viele bei uns beschweren
dass das ist scheiße
und wir müssen die sprache kennen und
lernen an literatur ist nicht wichtig
was arbeitest italienische italienische
schule ist die größte chance der welt
genau und ich bring francesco wenigstens
was richtiges deutsch oder
missgeburten fehlgeburt
denn die das den us open perfekt ok seht
ihr leute ich bringe mich was bei habe
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter so leute
jetzt geht's zurück war nicht bruder
tuck in triest also ich muss jetzt gehen